McCarthy is the founding curator of the
CIA exhibit Center at CIA headquarters
in Langley Virginia now from the
National Archives and Records
Administration
she discusses her new self-published
book spies pop flies and french fries in
it miss McCarthy reveals the content of
her private tours of the museum and
shares stories of various people
connected to the agency including
baseball player Moe Berg actress Marlene
Dietrich and TV chef Julia Child it's 45
minutes let's get started shall we
Lynn McCarthy comes to us all the way
from the mountains of Virginia the
Shenandoah Valley she was an employee of
the CIA for 24 years she helped create
the CIA exhibit Center which is close to
the pub it is closed to the public but I
understand some marvelous exhibit hall
and after her retirement she has gone to
create history is a hoot and is here
today she is also a great advocate of
preservation has won many awards and
legend Homewood should please welcome
Linda McCarthy well first of all let me
say what a pleasure it is to be back at
the archives on this the actual birth
date of the Office of Strategic Services
and everybody knows what we're talking
about when we say OSS and Office of
Strategic Services right OSS was so
social or oh so secret and it was all of
those and more and it was actually
founded on this date 60 years ago in
1942 now people ask me how I got
involved in the OSS because I was an
employee of the CIA which you probably
know is the modern-day successor to the
OSS I find the OSS and the people still
alive who served in it absolutely
fascinating and thankfully I have many
many friends who are themselves OSS
veterans and they graciously and
generously share their time and stories
with me so it's or it's a razz for me it
really is I enjoy it and I hope at the
end of the day you get a feeling for how
special the OSS really was I invite you
to when you're talking to Sam and the
archives to remember that all of the
declassified documents dealing with OSS
found their home here in the National
Archives why the CIA had to put them so
we're and it was the logical conclusion
that would come here we're to the extent
possible they're classified and you can
read them and some of them are
fascinating it gives you an eye on the
window of the world of these men and
women who were doing just incredible
deeds for this country sixty years ago
now yes the OSS did hire women actually
one-third of its 13,000 members were
women and I'm happy to say that because
back in the days yes back in the days
where we really had glass ceilings
that's an incredible number but William
J Donovan who headed the OSS founded the
OSS was its only director said I don't
care who you are as long as you can do
the job for me
and in that tremendous envelope he
brought baseball players actors film
director John Ford I'm sure some of his
stuff is here in fact speaking of John
Ford most of the US government footage
you see of something like d-day or any
place where the boys are going ashore
chances are John Ford and/or his men
that he brought with him from California
filmed that for the OSS John Ford always
wanted to be in the Navy but his
eyesight was bad Donovan said I don't
care about your eyes you know how to
work a camera so not only was he
documenting the war he was performing
strategic intelligence runs this
business of Normandy are we gonna land
at the pas-de-calais
or at Normandy it's John Ford and his
men going back and forth with aerial
sorties success suggesting to the
Germans that it's going to go down at
the pas-de-calais
why it's closer less of the channel to
traverse but things like that did you
know that John Ford was OSS is an
incredible story another one of my
favorites is Morris Moberg anybody heard
of Moe Berg
how do you know Moe
that's been my vision yes indeed he's
considered one of this country's
foremost atomic spies now think of that
in the context of baseball players I
mean I enjoy the sport immensely I have
very good friends in Cooperstown
but sometimes today's players when you
look at yesterday's players you wonder
where the relevancy is well with moe he
loved baseball absolutely adored
baseball but he also loved being an
espionage agent and quite honestly he
was probably doing that for this
government before there was an OSS now
you understand that OSS was this
nation's first centralized intelligence
service up until then in 1942 we had
hints suggestions minor attempts at this
business of collecting intelligence for
the United States government but the
business of collecting intelligence
actually goes all the way back to the
days of George Washington even before
Washington is considered this nation's
first spy master a guy with the wooden
teeth did all this stuff at Mount Vernon
established this nation one way he was
able to win the American Revolution was
the fact that he had a better espionage
network here in the States
in fact the head of the British
intelligence service at the time during
the American Revolution after things did
not go too well for him and his friends
down at Yorktown when this guy got back
to Great Britain he said to the Great
Britain press officials George
Washington did not out fight us he out
spied us so it gives you an idea of the
importance of espionage intelligence
gathering whatever euphemism you want to
ascribe to it to the business of this
nation and where we are even today the
different discussions you hear about
intelligence and where it has been and
where it's going but Washington started
this why less men and less material he
had to know where to put them to achieve
the stuff he wanted to achieve so up
until the time of the OSS there were
various and sundry attempts to get some
sort of information on our enemies and
quite frankly on our friends but nothing
was really solidified until June 13 1942
when Franklin Roosevelt who just loved
this business of spying said the William
J Donovan okay I'm going to make you
head of this Office of Strategic
Services
that's where you got this nation's first
formalized intelligence service now they
were an incredible group of men and
women we talked about some of the
entertainers one of my dear friends is
Betty McIntosh she herself was an OSS
morale operations officer and you read
what's going on in today's context of
trying to get those who would destroy us
too maybe better understand us that's
what Betty was doing with the Japanese
sixty years ago it's like does anybody
read history anymore
because it's right out there and it's in
these documents here at the archives
that talk about what we were doing in
terms of morale or psychological
operations however you want to tag it
it's the same thing now the other thing
about the OSS they had wonderful
training facilities oddly enough not all
of them have shall we say been
acknowledged anybody in here familiar
with Prince William Forest Park the
glorious stretch of open land in Prince
William County 495 the OSS trained there
it trained their kamo guys and a trained
their operational types one thing I like
to tell about that particular training
venue known as area a because that's
where the OSS taught its men and I have
yet to find one woman but I will
eventually to use it's one man sub the
Sleeping Beauty it was one of these
things probably just a little longer
than this table where you were those the
operative and the operator in other
words you had to know how to pilot that
thing to where you needed to go to
perform whatever little dastardly deed
you were going to do on behalf of the
United States government but they
practiced it there in Quantico Creek so
the next time you hear Quantico think oh
that's where the OSS the super-secret
spies were learning to use the Sleeping
Beauty which was their one band sub now
the head of research and development in
the OSS was one doctor Stanley Lovell
who Donovan affectionately referred to
as Professor Moriarty after the evil
genius in the Sherlock Holmes mysteries
so that gives you an idea of where these
men and women were coming from in terms
of hey let's try it and if it works
we'll do it there were many things they
tried that didn't but the litany of
things they did try and succeeded with
we're still enjoying the fruits of that
labor today one example of that is Julia
Child
anybody familiar with that name I hope
so she's considered by People magazine
and a few other these icons of the
American press one of the Trailblazers
of the twentieth century not so much for
what she did working with the OSS but of
course what she did in terms of cable
television public television but yes
Julia McWilliams at that time served
with the OSS and she will demure and say
she was just a clerk they were told to
say that women in particular and you
know nine times out of ten they really
were but others who showed some promise
or intuition toward another direction
were locked up didn't matter if they
wore a skirt or not that was not the
overriding concern the overriding
concern is can you do it and will you do
it well in the case of Julia McWilliams
she showed general Donovan their east
street everybody know where street is
down across from the Kennedy Center you
look up this glorious old buildings that
was the headquarters of the OSS it was
also the first headquarters of the CIA
why we didn't have that snappy new
building until Eisenhower came over and
turned the Spade full of dirt well after
the war had ended so the CIA started out
there - but that's rich Donovan and
company hung their hat establishing the
OSS well Julia was assigned there as an
administrative clerk and believe me I do
not denigrate clerks because I'm used to
getting paid and I know who's
responsible for them the finance clerks
when Julia's case she was doing that
sort of thing but somehow someway she
got selected for a special and fibia s--
task force and what they were doing was
looking for a way to basically protect
the lives of downed pilots and there
were a few of those and even maybe the
guy in the Sleeping Beauty ran into
trouble what are we gonna do to protect
these men one of the concerns with
sharks sharks are very curious animals
sharks can really mess up an
intelligence operation one of the way
sharks did this was we were having
problems with u-boats in the Atlantic
familiar at the Battle of the Atlantic
who's going to control the shipping
lanes part of the problem was we decided
the Allies Great Britain the United
States that perhaps we'd start blowing
you back u-boats out of the water which
would be probably the most rational way
of dealing with them and
required underwater and fibia s--
detonating devices and that was a good
idea except that sometimes sharks would
bother them now the worst thing that
could happen for the shark is that blew
him out of the water but the worst thing
that happened for the intelligence
mission is it exposed it so what did the
Germans do chances are it wasn't enough
of the limpets which is one of the
apparatuses they attach to the side of
you boat - totally you do the u-boat in
they'd simply move it it was a
cat-and-mouse game but along comes
things like shark repellent and it's the
idea of keep the Sharks away from the
men and the material so the next time
you think about Julia Child think about
her part in no pun intended cooking up
the shark recipe because she did and she
did it with a team of men and a couple
of other women right here in DC in the
tempo buildings if you know where they
were during the war but it's the idea
yes she was hired as a clerical but if
you showed some inclination in another
direction Donovan or whoever was in
charge was gonna say the favorite buzz
words let's try it
and sometimes that got them into trouble
needless to say but more often than not
with the OSS they had this can-do
attitude which quite frankly I don't
often see the bureaucracy being what it
is and I think sometimes that's a
stranglehold but Donovan paid a price
for that October 1 1945 Harry Truman
disbanded the OSS and that's the other
remarkable thing about the organization
it was only around four to two and a
half years but think of what strides it
made in that limited amount of time this
nation's first centralized intelligence
service it had proven the worth of
intelligence gathering which is a
euphemism for spying operationally
morale ops which again is just
psychological warfare and we're thinking
today how can we maybe make inroads into
other people's minds and ways of looking
at US history does repeat itself know
the OSS is a very good study in this now
some of the other luminaries one of my
favorites sterling Hayden
yeah his OSS mr. good-looking they
called him the Olympic goddess just
because he was just a wonderfully
good-looking man he was a well-paid
Hollywood actor and he didn't have to
leave to join the war effort he
gotten one of the many exemptions he not
only left the war effort but he left the
war effort to join the Marines and one
thing you have to remember about OSS it
was both civilian and military it didn't
matter if you had something up there
Donovan didn't care just can you do it I
need you for maybe one day maybe one
week maybe one year but that's the way
they work together with this in the case
of sterling Hayden he came out of Parris
Island and freshly minted lieutenant and
they made it to captain and Donovan said
how would you like to join my little
party and what he ended up doing for the
OSS was fishing some of our pilots and
some people trying to get out of the bad
place that was Yugoslavia at the time
out of the Adriatic just picking him out
he was always a sailor sterling Hayden
loved to sail he had to loves writing
and sailing and with the OSS that was
sailing right there and when he finished
his service he went right back to being
an actor again and won the Paramount lot
I think it was he was awarded the Silver
Star for his service as an OSS operative
but these are the kinds of luminaries
that Donovan was able to bring into the
fold that's where he got the oh so
social did these men and women like what
they were doing they will tell you was
the best years of their lives even Julia
Child says that to a certain extent and
if you think of one the wonderful things
she's done that's an incredible
endorsement basically established public
broadcasting as we know it and many
people credit her with the establishment
of the cable industry as we know it why
it's selective viewing so when you watch
Julia with the flambe and chasing the
liver on the table think of her as an
OSS employee because sometimes she does
too and they're very very proud of it
the other thing about the OSS when it
came to the derring-do was some of what
they created besides the sleeping beauty
dr. Moriarty one of my favorites of
something they developed called the
Beano it's simply a hand grenade
we basic hand grenade but it's the exact
dimensions circumference of an American
baseball why they figured everyone in
the service male/female civilian
military would have it one time or
another thrown a baseball so they'd have
a certain comfort level with that
particular feel and design so they had
this grenade called a Beno now why do
you think they call it a Beno
when you being a picture that's where it
comes from sometimes I think they had as
much fun creating actual artifact and
then naming it another one of these that
I really enjoy and quite frankly you can
see one of these up close and personal I
had the honor of doing a special display
on women operatives that's now being
featured at the womens military memorial
they're at the ceremonial gate of
Arlington National Cemetery and yeah I
finally got to talk about my spy gals
quite honestly it hadn't been done till
then when I was doing displays at the
CIA whenever I could kind of slip one of
my female operatives in I would but to
actually do a display that was devoted
entirely to women it hasn't been done
before so I had a great deal of fun with
that it was an unpainted canvas to me
well one of my favorites that I have on
display there is the doggie Doo
transmitter OSS developed a homing
device and you can see this on display
down at the spy gals display it's about
I guess three inches long and it looks
like something you do not want to step
in quite frankly you're gonna go walk
around it or at the very least it's
gonna blend into the train as a piece of
dirt litter well inside is for the time
a very sophisticated homing device it's
powered by three nickel-cadmium
batteries and I've included an x-ray of
its guts so you can see the actual
internal workings of it it's a homing
device and what people would do working
behind the lines you go out here oh
there's a nice flat area for an airdrop
whether you're trying to get men in men
out material in material out you need a
good space work they can do the airdrop
so you go out you Scout this there's no
cheap GPS then there's nothing like that
but you do have these little homing
devices so you basically activate that
thing and just throw it down and the
planes going over we'll pick it up and
go that's where they want the airdrop
but it looks like a piece of dog doo and
it's called the doggie doo transmitter
so if you get across the river sometime
before the end of the year it's there
till December take a look at the doggie
Doo transmitter developed for OSS and
quite frankly used by the CIA why these
things work so well during the Second
World War why would we just cast them
aside when we're fighting the Cold War
so yeah this is a lot of this stuff had
an incarnation in the the Cold War
another one of my favorites
it has to do with something that looks
an awful lot like a prophylactic we're
all adults here right it looks like that
and they fill it with some horrendous
substance that after a certain amount of
time would eat through not only the
rubber shield but an engine casing so
you get the little operative kind of
wheeling into town looking around French
Resistance use these things a lot pop
the hood throw it in there and after
fashioned this thing just ate through a
through it not only disabled the engine
it completely annihilated it it's not
like you could send the shade-tree
mechanic over and go repair the thing it
wasn't going to happen but I was an OSS
device another one of my favorites is
the exploding coal
OSS World War two was the advent of
plastic as we know it up until then you
didn't have the Tupperware parties
plastic was not the thing that it is
today
well back in World War two OSI saw a
wonderful venue for plastic they made
all sorts of little booby traps and
gizmos like that and one of my favorites
is the exploding coal where they simply
kept a cavity in something that looks
like coal made of plastic and in that
they put explosives usually plastique
and you get a little operative again one
of the guys just bicycling through town
they're in one of those control sectors
in France sees a train just kind of
scoffs it up there and the next thing
you know after he's long out of Dodge
the thing explodes you've disabled a
troop train material train whatever not
only have you done damage to that
particular vehicle but you probably tied
up the tracks incredible amount of stuff
this is the kind of stuff they dealt
with now speaking of operatives who work
behind the lines one of my favorite is
somebody perhaps you haven't heard of
anybody heard of Virginia Hall an
unpainted canvas I love it when I sit
when I do these little dog and ponies in
front of college groups or high school
groups I invariably get some young man
or woman that says oh yeah Virginia hall
is a doormat Mary Baldwin no well it is
I actually have seen it but not my
Virginia Hall she was incredible female
operative during World War two for the
OSS actually started out with the SOE
the British Intel
it's organization she's from nearby
Baltimore Maryland just across the river
she had a wooden leg she's known as the
famous limping lady of the OSS which is
an odd moniker until you read about her
this woman grew up in the upper strata
of Baltimore went to nice schools but
decided she wanted a career in the
Foreign Service a career in the Foreign
Service during the days before World War
two didn't get too much beyond that desk
quite frankly that was it if you were
female
this woman was terribly gifted she had a
command of languages she was socially
placed so she knew how to behave with a
group of people so she got herself
assigned to different post as a clerk
with the American Embassy's actually had
a hunting accident where she suffered
the loss of a right leg below the knee
so she had to wear a wooden leg that did
not stop her did not stop her at all
when world war ii broke out she found
out that she couldn't get beyond that
death so what did she do she went to the
Brits and they hired her and it was the
Brits who taught her how to blow up this
that and the other thing saw the toward
and things like that she got very good
at it she worked behind the lines for
the Brits she actually earned the member
of the British Empire from the king now
after a fashion it dawned on her you
know I'm an American I think I'd like to
work for the American intelligence
service and by that time she had a
pedigree and Donovan yes yes come work
for me and I'll put you back behind the
lines if that's what you want and that's
exactly what she wanted even though she
was known in France had to do with one
of the double agents who blew her cover
when she was working for the Brits where
did she ask to go back to France why she
had a networking place there people she
knew she worked with she trusted I can
make great strides on behalf the Allied
cause if you just put me back into
France and of course the people in
Washington are going that's ludicrous
you're not she says no leave me alone
with this I can handle it
one thing about Virginia very statuesque
very nice bearing so how does she
disguise herself walked with a sloop as
an old peasant woman and because she
knew new French new German she just
blended right in
now the wooden leg that presented
another problem it did cause her to walk
with a discernible limp but she learned
to slooping
actually pull it along to where you
could not tell that that woman in that
peasant garb had a wooden leg so what is
she doing in occupied France for the
Americans well she's making preparations
for d-day which as we know was one big
party there along the Atlantic Wall
one of the first things that happened
when the word went out that d-day was
going down was they cut the
communication lines so the Germans were
basically stranded they didn't couldn't
communicate with each other in fact
there's some speculation that Hitler
didn't really understand that this was
indeed going down in Normandy and so the
pas-de-calais
until well after d-day had gotten down
why because Virginia and other
operatives working with the French
Resistance known as the MOT key which is
Corsican for wild underbrush so that
gives you an idea of where these people
were coming from had been doing things
like cutting the telegraph line in the
case of Virginia
she actually added to her credibility
and currency by learning Morris code so
she became a wireless operator her own
wireless operator during the day she'd
do things like make goat cheese and then
go into town and sell the goat cheese
all the while listening to what's going
on the Germans are occupying they're
saying things loose lips sink ships very
good intelligence operative on the
ground she takes this information back
after selling her goat cheese to where
she has stashed the radio and takes the
radio and I've held it it's a I don't
know 50 pounds but it's deadweight and
climbs to usually a hayloft or someplace
higher elevation and starts keying
information to headquarters London and
it's very important information so when
the mckeon company cut the lines people
who could do that were invaluable that's
why we were able to communicate with our
men and women behind the lines and the
ones that were advancing across the
fields of Normandy now oddly enough she
had some problems with this leg but she
never never let it stop her in terms of
what she wanted to do one of the things
she constantly sought was the socks that
you put between the stump and the wooden
apparatus itself to cushion it is it one
time she had to hike across the Pyrenees
I believe it was yeah and the stump
became very bloody so
she was very concerned about keeping
enough of the socks to keep the leg from
rubbing against what was left of the
stump so every once and again she'd have
to wire headquarters London for a supply
of these things and after a while they
knew who it was with this rather cryptic
odd message on the other let end it went
something like Cuthbert is giving me
trouble but I can cope Cuthbert was the
code name she gave her leg so anybody on
the other end listening that would know
oh it's Virginia Hall she's having a
problem with her amputated leg send her
some of those socks ordinarily that
worked just fine
however there was an instance where we
had an unknowing little individual on
the other end in london listening to
this rather odd message Cuthbert is
giving you trouble he wires with our
keys back if Cuthbert is giving you
trouble have him eliminated in other
words shoot yourself in the foot again
no no that won't work
why did she have to disguise her wooden
leg well remember she's well known she
is known as the most dangerous operative
in all of Allied for ants by the Germans
themselves the woman with the wooden leg
is the most dangerous allied agent male
or female in all of occupied France so
if it went out over the wire and the
Germans were listening in we know they
were listening him that this person was
having trouble with an amputee Virginia
Hall and they'd immediately find out her
location and that would probably be the
end of her and whatever she was doing on
behalf of the Allies so that's why she
developed this little code about
Cuthbert she always referred to the leg
as Cuthbert now I mention again the
women spies display she's one of the
seven women I included in it why because
people invariably don't know of her and
I think that's sad
because she did incredible work for this
country in fact you're in the MBE from
the Brits and this nation bestowed upon
her the Distinguished Service Cross
which as you know is the second highest
military award for bravery
after the Medal of Honor and she was a
civilian female she was the first
civilian female to receive this award
and is because of her derring-do and
occupied France now at the end of the
war Truman had disbanded the OSS
general Donovan went up to Truman says I
have this agent and you might want to
confer this decoration upon her she's
been approved for the Distinguished
Service Cross and we think it's worthy
of a White House ceremony and Truman
agreed
so I cable went out to where Virginia
was still in London cleaning up after
the war the President of the United
States would like to bestow upon you in
a White House ceremony the Distinguished
Service Cross please respond
well Virginia gets this and she goes
she's mortified for a couple of reasons
one she kind of like the undercover
world and if there was going to be some
successor to the OSS and the Cold War
era she'd like to be a part of it and
you don't do that blow your cover at a
White House ceremony where c-span might
show up you just don't do that that's
not good etiquette the other thing she
says I am busy here I she felt obligated
to the men and women who had basically
sustained her as a covert operative and
just know I'm tired I'm busy so she got
this cable back to headquarters here in
OSS in Washington I'm sorry but I still
have work to do here she stiffed the
President of the United States now what
they did do when she wrapped things up
and got back across the Atlantic
Donavan in a very quiet ceremony there
in the E Street headquarters building we
talked about conferred upon her the DSC
with only her mother in attendance so
that gives you an idea of this woman's
focus and dedication to what she was
doing so I included her even though I
have luminaries in there like Julia
Child another one Marlena Dietrich
anybody know that she did
psyops morale ops it was the idea that
she was a very very popular woman in
Germany sad to say that when she kind of
renounced Hitler he did not treat her
too well so she renounced her German
citizenship in 1937 became an American
citizen and what the OSS wanted her to
do in the worst kind of way was to
basically perform American songs popular
American songs in German and the OSS to
its black ops program black operations
program would beam these back to guess
where behind the lines in Germany and
you got
oh it's Marlena singing about wife in
Germany I'm so lonely I just want to
throw down in my web
go home some cases that happen now what
they did do was get a poor guy to
translate these songs overnight into
German and Lily Marley's that I'd be
honored to do this they put her in a
recording studio and she recorded all
these popular songs that were used to
hearing of the era and they beamed them
back to Germany one of the reasons they
wanted to do it in addition to having
them think about putting down their arms
and going home was we wanted the Germans
to hang around on our radio frequency
and listen to quite frankly the
propaganda why we were fighting this war
and why the American side was gonna win
but you know they got wise to that after
fashion they just started turning it off
however if they thought there was a
chance that little Marlene was gonna
show up any time on a record and start
singing one of their songs one of the
American songs in their language we'd
hang around they'd listen to the entire
transmission so not only were they get
these model and songs about Germany and
German they were getting American
propaganda so that's a little more lean
she's featured down there too and
another one which was not OSS but I
mentioned her because up until 1937 she
herself was an American citizen was
Josephine Baker familiar with her an
incredible story she worked for the
French Resistance because at that point
she was a French citizen why had not
been treated too well in terms of civil
rights here in this nation so she found
a welcomed audience in Paris who
understood her rather risk a review and
she settled there spoke French
beautifully the Parisians loved her so
when world war ii broke out she wanted
to do something like Julian McWilliams
in Virginia Hall they could have stayed
home but they didn't in the case of
Josephine Baker she basically said to
the head of the French Resistance you
may use me as you wish and they did
why because Josephine Baker had on trade
to just about every venue there on the
European continent and even in North
Africa why she's Josephine Baker she
could even be performing a review there
so one of the neat stories about her and
I won't dwell on her cos all I want you
to go look at the display across the
river
sheet music she's a performer she's
gonna have sheet music well in the
margins an invisible ink the resistance
had written all sorts of classified
information she was passing back and
forth so until 1937 she was an American
said
and having been born in st. Louis so I
have included her as well now back to
the OSS for a second how would you like
to play with some OSS toys yeah okay I
do have a collection of toys and people
think I'm denigrating the artifacts when
I call them toys no to those of us who
revere these things they are just
wonderful toys that OSS concocted during
World War two where did I get them well
quite frankly a lot of the OSS give them
to me why I think they trust me with the
artifact and the story it represents and
the service they themselves are very
proud of and they have an understanding
for me that I will never sell it
I will never trade it what I'd like to
do with it eventually when I get through
doing these educational outreach
programs like this just give it to a
museum just so others can enjoy it but
in the meantime I'm having a lot of fun
with them the other thing you familiar
with that entity known as eBay you can
get some good stuff on eBay I just
caution you to be careful because
there's so many well I'll be polite and
say reproductions out there
reproductions being sold as the original
article you just got to know who you're
buying from and that happens whether
you're buying Civil War OSS even Cold
War artifacts but this stuff that I have
here today comes from a collection of
places and we'll start with my favorite
the caltrops I cover them up so you
people aren't looking at them while I'm
talking ok white gloves why the white
gloves yes we have an archivist here
how'd you know that sir there you go
hand oils hand hair anything is oily all
this is very acidic when you're talking
about old metal old documents like here
in the archives you come visit Sam and
you want to look at something the first
thing he's gonna do is hand you the
white gloves and make sure that you keep
off of it what I have here are three
caltrops thank you soon anybody know
what a caltrop is that's where it
started yes it's the idea if you [ __ ]
a horse you [ __ ] an army it started
back in the Crusades is where these
things gain their fame now that's
inherently cruel but it's also
inherently effective we use it today we
use them in counterterrorism Ray's does
that phrase ring a bell to anyone
terrorism when the Israelis had their
plane hijacked and on eBay they wanted
it back one of the first things they did
was lying the tarmac with hundreds
thousands of these things so that plane
could not take off and there is a
modern-day equivalent commercial
equivalent of it here even in DC you he
erroneously end up in the wrong parking
garage and those things go up behind you
and you're not gonna back up because you
know it's gonna happen to your tire and
maybe your tailpipe
they're just caltrops on a strip that's
all it is let's start with this guy he's
my oldest one
caltrop they tell me it's from the
French meaning thistle or the Middle
English whoever you talk to but it comes
from a derivative of thistle and if you
look at these things and use your
imagination I guess there is a thistle
in there but if you notice this thing is
made from one continuous piece of metal
it's u n-- assembly any way you throw it
it's gonna land prague up the idea is
put one behind and one in front the OSS
errs many of whom I spoke to about
things like caltrops a Linda we always
ask for as many of these things as they
would hand us but always we wanted at a
minimum to why one for the front and one
for the back it crippled buses planes
anything jeeps where you've got a rubber
tire now this one for being an early
version of the world war two model had a
particular problem
OSS was the advent excuse me world war
two was the advent of the self-sealing
tire that was a big deal put the tire
around this they just wrapped and
theoretically you could go down the
route you could you could you could you
but you'd get where you're going
eventually OSS is new we can do better
than that so they came up with this
little guide which has an air cavity
anywhere you throw it it's been land
prong up tire would wrap itself around
there but because there was an air
channel there would feed directly out
and there you'd have your flat tire
where this might disable it a few miles
down the road one of my favorites this
nasty little thing if you handle it
wrong you'll need a tetanus shot
this is called the Christmas tree
caltrop looks like a Christmas tree
I have 35 of these because I had an
opportunity to get them and someone
asked me what are you gonna do a 35 of
these
line my driveway when people tear up and
don't want to slow down but more
important I can trade this for something
but this is a Christmas tree caltrop
there are ninja caltrops martial artists
use them today they usually are smaller
they fit in your hand you just throw
them out when you see somebody advancing
toward you whether it's a person or a
horse and it's gonna stop them pretty
darn good in the case of this you can
use these as a defensive weapon kind of
holding it like that that's your last
resort
strategically placed you could kill
somebody with one of these but I hang on
to it thinking one day on the Beltway
we're gonna run off by a tractor-trailer
I'll be ready those are Cal trucks and
I've made kind of a science of studying
these things there's one that I'd love
to get from the world war one generation
that actually had prongs about yay long
and they buried those around the
trenches in the sand to keep you from
crawling over anything like that I've
seen those for sale and the last one I
saw went for a little more than I was
willing to pay for it but caltrops right
up from the Crusades to today and this
little guy this is the matchbox camera
so named because it resembles a box of
wooden matches it was meant to be
something you could easily put in your
pocket I draw any attention to unless
you're coming into the archives you have
to call them ahead and say you're
bringing this stuff because this is
gonna set off the magnetometers and all
sorts of things needless to say when I
do these talks I'm going to Maui to do a
talk in September sadly this stuff can't
follow me you can imagine what kind of
chaos this would create in an airport
today seriously so I don't even bother I
don't want to confiscated and pounded
certainly kept but with this guy it's a
16-millimeter people think primarily to
take people know which used principally
to take documents why you want to steal
the plans to the lido Burma Road but you
don't want to walk out with them like
this first of all you're going to draw
attention to your so secondly somebody's
going to notice eventually they're gone
they're gonna figure who was the last
person to have these things and chances
are they might finger you but if you're
in there surreptitiously photographing
them and then you walk out and stick
this in your pocket called pocket litter
in the spy trade it's kind of innocuous
no one's really gonna sound the alarm
unless you try to get on a plane
Dulles Airport with it now the other
neat thing about this to further
camouflage it this is plane and hasn't
been used but if they were dropping you
into Britain you got a British back
match motif if you're getting into
France you had a French logo pasted on
just something to camouflage it even
more this was used right up through
parts of the Cold War why because it was
so darned effective it's the embodiment
as these are of the KISS principle
familiar with that keep it simple stupid
and it is very effective cheap to
operate cheap to manufacture it easy to
conceal but darn good at what it was
designed to do and OSS whether you're
male or female they use these things all
the time so it gives you a little flavor
about the OSS does anyone have any
questions yes sir quite honestly I don't
know there has a lot to do that's sort
of subject with what's been Declassified
and I'm just not sure what's out there
yet I'm just not sure so I have to err
on the side of caution and say I just
don't know how do you know Julian China
how did you know about Julia in China
Julia ended up in China how one of
Betty's Macintosh's favorite story she
and Julia flew over the hump together
that mountain range that people dread
and Julia was sitting there cool as a
cucumber reading a book everybody else
on the plane is white knuckled there's
Juliet just reading a book what she did
over there she was head of the registry
and that is to say every piece of paper
that came and went out of that
particular OSS office she saw she had to
approve in some way shape or form she
called it after a fashion the top secret
which but she was getting just a little
nervous looking at all this heady stuff
that she was reading day in and day out
but that's principally what she did when
she got in China it was in the Far East
where she met Paul child Julia Child
Paul was himself an OSS operative Oh
Namath this man could do it take
pictures draw pictures
new languages he was one of those
operatives that you wanted working for
you and he and Julia struck up a
friendship became a romance devoted to
each other they married after they got
back here anybody yes sir
I just found out from my friend Betty
that Betty Macintosh actually took a
course of Morales from Margaret Mead and
I was interviewing Betty I'm starting an
oral history of the LSS that were kind
enough to share this stuff with me and
we'll humor me long enough to serve me
lunches I'm taping their little stories
to tell me some of the intimate C's
dealing with the OSS because they're
just now getting to the point where
they're comfortable discussing it and
Betty mentioned almost casually that she
took a course in Psychological
operations from Margaret Mead and you
listen to me on the tape and I'm
blathering you studied Margaret Mead yes
Margaret Mead and her husband at the
time were two very big morale operations
types for the OSS you watched movies on
TV today you watch movies where you have
a James Bond a flamboyant
you know very ostentatious spy but in
lectures that some of you attended the
past dealing with submarines it seems
like those who are involved with
submarines the thrill was not getting
attention but sneaking up on someone
staying behind them learning all that
you could and then sneaking away never
being known you know that you were
following him is that the same kind of
mentality that OSS agents had that you
would interview me what was there what
was the thrill of doing what they did to
a person that they were happy to do what
they did for their country I'm happy to
hear that the other thing it was fun
giulia Betty all the people I've talked
to will say there was some of the best
days of their life but in terms of the
actual actual operational aspect this
was heady stuff and you know women in
particular there's that death but not if
you could show an inclination another
direction you were doing some really
heady stuff it was the thrill of the
chase it was working with contemporaries
for a change
and it was doing something that was
vital to the war effort so yeah they
loved that service and many of them
bolon the fact that mr. Truman in 1945
disbanded it tell us about
you left the the settle intelligence
agency in 1997 and you formed histories
of who somebody tell us more about that
when I was at the agency my last 10
years I ran something I started called
the CIA exhibit center and if you want
job Security's start your own little
niche in a government building what I
did was create a museum why I found
these toys fascinating and when people
saw that I had a certain reverence for
them guess what they started surfacing
now these were federal property of
course there were former OSS who would
turn them in to the CIA because there
was a succeeding element there but there
was no place to put them I was working
in a place that dealt with old books and
these people God loved them thought I
must be dealing with old things so I was
happy to take the toys and that's how
the museum started now when I left the
agency in 97 I had collected some of
these on my own and I decided you know
if people were happy hearing about the
toys and the men and women who used them
on the inside imagine the reception I
get on the outside
no one has thrown me off the stage yet
and I've talked to very young very old
all kinds of audiences so I thought you
know this might be a vehicle for my
private life so I started history as a
hoot why because history is incredibly
fun I don't find it boring I'm sorry for
those who do but chances are when they
hear talk about the caltrops they don't
think it's boring either so what I do is
through my company as I go around
Sam humors me once or twice a year and
talk about different aspects of this
kind of stuff having written the book I
can kind of peddle that - so that's my
company and I have fun with it
thank you all for coming we're gonna
adjourn to this corner of the room where
we will now have our book signing and
you can ask more questions to Lynda
McCarthy thank you all very much
Linda McCarthy is a 24-year veteran of
the Central Intelligence Agency and the
founding curator of the CIA exhibit
Center spies pop flies and french fries
is published by history is a hoot
incorporated for more information write
them at the address on your screen
p o-- box 285 markham virginia 2 2 6 4